what was that third one that you said
something about toxic masculinity Beth
can you just say that one
again that it's not a thing I feel like
dealing to elaborate yeah explain what
do you mean by that I feel like I feel
like masculinity is a thing kind of like
femininity is a thing if you're toxic
you're a toxic person I don't feel like
saying a masculine man is toxic because
of his masculinity as a thing I feel
like men are men can be toxic just like
women can be toxic I
think controversial but I think a lot of
feminists are highly toxic just in their
thought of the
anti-man uh anti-man rhetoric
surrounding feminists this you know
these days so I feel like people are
toxic regardless of their
masculinity what about this notion I
think the thing that gets brought up a
lot when the flag of toxic masculinity
gets flown is this idea of man
male vulnerability right you we had a
conversation about this on our show this
past Saturday there seems to be this
ever increasing pressure on men to open
up their feelings and make sure they're
crying on their woman's shoulder and
going to therapy and that sort of thing
I mean and any sort of advice to the
contrary is toxic masculinity what what
is what is all the ladies on the panel's
thought about vulnerability in men is it
necessary is it a turnoff to you or or
what does that mean to
you I think that there's a point where
um if I'm dating somebody I want them to
be vulnerable with me but
um there's like a point where it's too
much when does it become too much
where's that line um like an example
like where you got like the ick off a
guy or something like that like ah that
guy's a little too too much of a [__]
yeah he was just kind of relying on me
for his emotions I guess um and I don't
know that's just
it's a turn off as soon as that happens
I feel like I don't want to be
responsible for somebody else's emotions
and their day-to-day life and their mood
if I do something and they don't like it
and it just makes
them I don't know what would they do
reactive like a reactive guy I
guess okay so he's a little bit more
like um emotional can't regulate his
tions okay yeah exactly okay but can you
give us an example of where that
positive for you said because you want
to guy to be vulnerable to a certain
point so like what does that look like
before it gets to that sort of critical
mass um I mean it could go in a good way
um I want somebody like I want to know
that somebody loves me and I want them
like to share their emotions with me but
as soon as they start relying on me for
their day-to-day emotions that they're
having as when it I feel like it goes
too
far who else I was gonna say too or if
they're like constantly the whole day
they have to give you a play byplay of
their entire day and they expect you to
respond so I don't want that I don't
care what they're doing 24 I don't care
what they're eating I don't care I just
want to live my life I want them to have
their own life because it's super
unattractive for men to just like be
like hey you know I had this for lunch I
don't care exactly I'm I'm laughing
because I because I used to do that in
my 20s and it was probably the stupidest
[__] that I ever you know it's
embarrassing for me to raise my hand and
be like hey you know I used to do that
gay [__] um but yeah you want to like
you want to say less guys like you have
two ears in a mouth use them in that
ratio for [__] sakes and you know only
speak when you actually have something
to say that's actually interesting to a
check that's captivating that
demonstrates your resourcefulness that
your social network is is cool but like
what you had for lunch or what you did
at work today they don't want to hear it
they really know what's interesting
about about that point that Christy
brings up is that there's also
conventional wisdom or there's a lot of
this advice pared by women saying I want
to know what you're doing all the time I
want to know that you care I want to
know that you're thinking about me I
want reassurance but then as soon as
that happens they get the H like I don't
need to they they say they want that but
they actually thrive on the mystery and
the unknown of what you're up to maybe
you're out with another girl I don't
know where you are maybe he's doing this
oh I better text him right as opposed to
you know
so that's what's so interest because you
hear this a lot from from women they say
no I I love a guy that's texting me and
me only all the time and then it happens
and they're like holy [__] until it gets
annoying and they're turned off yeah I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clip's from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out